it's january and you know what that
means time to drop new trailers for this
year's blockbuster films keep an eye out
for the third jurassic world the buzz
lightyear movie top gun finally hitting
theaters and of course more entries in
the unstoppable mcu multiverse madness
and thor love and thunder but before we
talk about the mcu and how to stop it in
today's episode there's one trailer
specifically that i want to cover thrill
driver in a portion of the video that's
been sponsored by nissan official car of
the movie in a year that's decidedly
absent of anything fast or furious we
have ourselves a new franchise looking
to take the pole position thrill driver
though the trailer doesn't give us too
much to work with here in terms of plot
or character details we can immediately
tell that it's hitting all the key beats
of a car heist movie dave batista here
being called out as the point man
basically confirms it the point man is
basically the member of the team who
leads at the front of the group but
thrill driver doesn't seem to be just
any heist movie actually seems to come
with a twist and we can tell based on
the movie's casting you see behind the
driver's seat we have eugene levy in the
lead role pulling stunt driving
maneuvers but eugene isn't the type of
guy that you'd expect for this sort of
role he's better known as being a normal
dorky dad in most of the things that
he's done in the past so if i were to
guess thrill driver looks to be
following the recent film trend of
normal everyday guys suddenly turning
out to have a special set of skills that
turn them into action superstars once
they're pushed to the limit pretty darn
surprised that no one's tapped into that
genre yet good on thrill driver to see
the white space it also appears to be a
tour de force for a new model of car as
well the all-new nissan z honestly the
only thing i can't wrap my head around
is the whole dragon thing at the end
yeah not sure if that transformation is
meant to be literal or figurative maybe
this is a car heist fantasy i mean
another full throttle franchise just
went to space so i'll believe anything
these days anyway as other high octane
franchises have descended into self
parody as of late thrill driver looks to
be following the playbook to create the
next massively successful car dynasty a
special thanks to nissan for sponsoring
that segment to see more of thrill
driver check out
thrilldrivermovie.com and now since
we're talking about successful film
dynasties let's talk about how to kill
one off you ready for this mcu
hello internet welcome to film theory
where we politely remind you to be like
the hulk and smash that subscribe button
so this is me and this is the huge pile
of money that spider-man no way home has
made i don't know about you but standing
here it seems safe to say that the mcu
is back in full swing at this point now
that might seem like a no-brainer
statement to say but think back to the
end of 2019 the mcu was really at its
most vulnerable point endgame had just
wrapped up a decades-long narrative saga
making it the perfect time to hop off
the old story train and audiences
weren't the only ones actors at the end
of their contracts were on the way out
too leaving beloved characters in a gray
area as they changed hands for the next
wave of films making matters worse for
marvel they would have to prove the
value of continuing on to phase 4 using
the lackluster lineup consisting of an
already dead character a never heard of
before character and the eternals a
comic that flopped in a movie that no
one knew what to make of based on the
trailers overall just a very weak launch
lineup for season two of this thing
marvel fatigue was truly starting to set
in and this was before four mcu
streaming projects all came out within
the same 12 month period so things were
tenuous at best and then there was a
giant global pandemic that crippled
theaters because suddenly going to see a
movie was the equivalent of playing
russian roulette what started as a
precarious position for the mcu at the
end of 2019 really became the worst case
scenario in the two years that
immediately followed and yet here we are
the mcu just got another billion dollar
entry with spider-man no way home disney
got into a very public very ugly lawsuit
against their black widow that just kind
of blew over and everyone got richer as
a result big guns like iron man and
captain america retiring were supposed
to make audiences lose interest but nope
turns out new characters and former
second stringers have immediately found
big fandoms of their own even the
eternals this weird mess of a movie that
opened to surprisingly negative reviews
from major critics is currently cruising
to a pretty healthy post-pandemic 400
million dollar global box office which
is higher than both black widow and more
shockingly to me into the verse so yeah
seems like we can scratch bad ratings
the avengers retirement and global
plague virus off the list of things that
could have maybe spelled the end of this
series of films at this point the
question no longer seems to be when the
marvel cinematic universe will end but
rather if anything can put an end to
this seemingly indestructible force and
that my friends is the question we aim
to explore today realistically unless
we're solving for super unlikely
scenarios like asteroid impact or the dc
extended universe actually getting its
act together what can possibly kill off
marvel for years this channel has done
episodes looking into what can take down
unstoppable meta humans like deadpool
and magneto but today i want to look at
what can bring down the ultimate
collection of superheroes what is strong
enough to stop the mouse first it's
important to understand who we're
actually up against here when we're
talking about marvel what we're really
talking about is disney and disney
doesn't do cycles of beginnings and
endings the same way everyone else does
it's actually ingrained in the company's
origins back before disney started
making movies if a film failed at the
box office that was usually the last you
heard of it television was only just
coming into being reruns weren't even a
word yet and the idea of re-releasing
anything but a successful movie would
have been a pretty big novelty it's
actually estimated that more than 50
percent of movies made before 1950 are
literally gone forever because unless
they were a big hit nobody bothered to
save a physical copy of it 50
think about how much lost media that is
but disney originated in the world of
animation a world that is all about
saving and re-utilizing assets before
computers animators would have to draw
each cell by hand so to make life easier
the animators would just draw different
characters over the same cells classic
example of this sleeping beauty's final
dance is copied identically for beauty
and the beast's iconic ballroom vaults
stuff like this makes it immediately
apparent why it would never make sense
to throw this away everything has value
did you know that fantasia allison
wonderland pinocchio peter pan even
bambi were all either box office
disappointments or just outright money
losing films when they first came out in
fact things got so rough for disney that
the shareholders basically forced walt
to just do snow white again in the form
of cinderella so he could have an actual
hit so then why are all these considered
to be among the most recognized and
creatively accomplished disney films of
all time pr where the bigger film
studios at the golden age of cinema
mostly disdained television as the
lesser medium that would cheapen the art
form sound familiar much uncle walt got
himself a tv show to promote all the
stuff that his studio was doing while
also rehabilitating the reputations of
the disney movies that didn't initially
get the best reception in theaters
perhaps an outstanding example of this
occurs in the opening scenes of our
cartoon feature bambi as a result a
generation of baby boomers remember them
as foundational disney classics because
shrewdly disney regularly replayed the
most memorable parts of those films on
his show eventually priming them for a
more successful theatrical re-release
and permanent life as physical
attractions at disney parks for an
excellent example of this just check out
sorcerer's apprentice mickey with that
red robe and his wizard's hat probably
the second most famous mickey look ever
and it's from fantasia one of the least
successful big disney movies of all time
now that is taking a lemon and turning
it into lemonade now with that context
ask yourself this why was such a huge
chunk of avengers end game dedicated to
revisiting events from for the dark
world of all movies the most panned mcu
production up to that point well maybe
in true walt form endgame was making
that movie cool to revisit because well
it might not be good but let me tell ya
it pays off 13 movies down the line as
part of this epic conclusion and you see
that's disney's other little secret to
success here well everyone thinks that
they're in the movie business they're
really not or at least that's just a
small portion of what they care about
they're actually in the ip business
owning cultural touchstones and then
making money from all the clothes toys
costumes food tie-ins and rides that
stem off of it honestly we could
probably dedicate a whole video just to
the idea that disney much like
mcdonald's is a company just as much
about theme parks and real estate as
they are about movies and tv shows but
uh that's a digression for another day
if you're interested in seeing it it is
an episode that will come out so hit
that subscribe button to make sure you
don't miss it but you see that's the
secret sauce here for other movie
studios a film needs to earn a lot of
money at the box office for it to be
worth making for disney earning a lot of
the box office is just icing on the cake
wow a lot of people paid to go see our
commercial for the new captain america
costume the new captain america shield
toy the new captain america experience
at the exciting avengers campus at
california adventure the largely empty
theme park that no one really cared
about again this is them taking straw
and spinning it into gold disney isn't
interested in marvel for just its movies
it's interested in marvel as an ip
creation machine and as long as that
brand is able to keep generating more
fodder for merchandising opportunities
well then it's doing its job and thus
the movies will keep coming speaking of
that marvel theme park by the way
avengers campus everything you need to
know for today's theory is right there
in the name campus a term that denotes
training turnover and mobility kind of
like a university or an office
environment where new recruits and new
ideas are constantly going to be cycled
in and out there's a reason this
experience isn't heavily branded around
one particular superhero it's because
they're all disposable except ironically
enough spider-man the one they don't own
it's built in a way where the dr strange
portal show can be swapped out for the
wandavision magic show or the agatha
magic show or the america chavez magic
show the success or failure of one
character doesn't matter to the mcu
another will rise to take its place and
disney is comfortable with that so the
mcu can't die because disney won't let
it die yeah kind of if anything goes
wrong it'll just pull a star war it'll
take a break for a year or two and then
build its way back up slowly kind of
like a canceled celebrity no matter how
bad it gets they rarely stay canceled
for long but there's another factor here
that's propping up the mcu and it's the
rest of the movie industry you ever
heard the phrase too big to fail it was
a phrase that was used a lot back in
2008 when the global economy collapsed
due to um well it collapsed due to a lot
of shady stuff but basically it was all
tied back to the housing market anyway
at the time the phrase too big to fail
was used to describe companies that were
seen as the equivalent of a load-bearing
beam for a house there's a lot of stuff
depending on the stability of that beam
if you pull the beam out the whole rest
of the structure is going to collapse so
when the beam starts having a problem
you don't pull it out and replace it
instead you repair it or you do what it
takes to reinforce it anyway the reason
i bring all this up is because the movie
industry seems to see the mcu in the
same way sure every other studio would
love to beat marvel at the box office
but nobody actually wants to see him
lose because i suspect if marvel loses
everyone does the mcu might indeed be
too big to fail consider this back in
the day movie studios routinely tried to
beat each other at the box office often
releasing films competing for the same
audiences with similar premises and
similar genres on the same weekend just
a one random example here in 1986 the
original top gun spent several weeks
duking it out for the number one spot
against another manly action movie cobra
or you'd have summers where one studio
would put out their volcano disaster
movie dante's peak and a week or two
later someone else would challenge it
with their volcano disaster movie you'll
have a hell of a time but if you hadn't
noticed or you're younger than say 20
this isn't really the case now now
studios tend to get projects out of each
other's way disney and warner brothers
don't open their marvel and dc movies
against one another on the same weekends
if you watch the weekly release
schedules there's usually only one big
new movie per genre per weekend and when
a giant release like an mcu feature hits
everybody clears out of the way so sure
in theory in film theory it wouldn't be
all that hard for a rival studio to see
something like eternals or black widow
on the slate some of the riskier bets
for marvel and then release their movie
on the same weekend to steal away some
of marvel's thunder tap it at the knees
from there the rival studio would take
the number one slot for the weekend and
show the world that marvel isn't the
invincible force that it appears to be
suddenly the seal of marvel's vacuum
hold over the movie industry is broken
mickey gets an embarrassing black eye
and press and pr momentum carries it
from there i mean we've seen this done
before with other juggernauts it's
actually how the reality tv show
survivor managed to kill off who wants
to be a millionaire back when it was
king of prime time which in and of
itself is a really cool story hopefully
i can figure out a way to shove into one
of these someday i mean venom 2's
opening weekend of 90 million actually
would have passed three out of four
marvel projects this year it would have
beaten eternals black widow and shangshi
heck even f9 would have come close there
is vulnerability in these movies i just
don't think anyone actually wants to
take their shots why not what's everyone
so afraid of well i suspect the fear is
that marvel is so big that if they go
down way too much of the movie business
is brought down with them it's that too
big to fail problem all over again right
now people are excited to go see new
marvel movies on big screens that is
what's single-handedly keeping the
theater experience alive if marvel
suddenly goes away well theaters take
another big hit the media that covers
marvel takes a big hit movie culture as
a whole takes a huge step back and
nothing can truly fill the vacuum right
now at least nothing in hollywood can
fill that vacuum right now but youtube
can tick-tock can at the end of the day
going to see a movie is an expensive
inconvenience surveys report that 70 of
people would rather just stay at home to
watch a movie and that isn't just a
pandemic thing this was being reported
on back in 2014 and again in 2017 in the
middle of marvel mania while box office
earnings have been surging every year
the actual number of tickets sold has
been on a steady decline since 2002 as
fewer people are going to the movies
simply put it's an antiquated
entertainment format that as tvs have
gotten better and better has lost more
and more of its relevance marvel is the
one thing currently that can get people
to make going into the theater to watch
a movie a priority in their life and if
it suddenly goes away movies have lost
their last major foothold that time then
goes to cheaper more convenient
entertainment options video games
streaming social media digital video and
maybe they realize that there are
suddenly more fun things to do on a
friday night than sitting in a sticky
theater i mean in the last four years
alone the number of kids who watch
online video every day has more than
doubled it's not so much marvel vs other
movies it's the medium of movies versus
every other form of entertainment and in
that fight marvel is throwing far and
away the biggest hands so will the mcu
go away no because disney and the entire
movie industry will make sure that it
doesn't go away anytime soon but will
the invincibility of the mcu go away
yeah each year it's becoming more
vulnerable there's only so many times
that you can pull an end game or a no
way home you can't keep one-upping
yourself forever in fact scaling out
that big that quickly might have even
shot themselves in the foot everything
less than a three-way movie collab feels
missable feels like non-essential
viewing at this point so in summary what
can kill marvel well a few things as i
see it one over extension of the brand
and over emphasis of all the streaming
stuff i mean no one wants going to the
movies to feel like having to do
homework two kevin feige just piecing
out as the guy who's been driving this
whole ship towards one creative vision
after all we saw what happened with both
star wars and harry potter bad
leadership immediately destroys what
otherwise seems like a bulletproof brand
but the biggest thing that can truly
kill off the mcu is number three us it's
stuff like this video the analog horror
stuff that we cover here on youtube the
indie games that are happening over on
game theory stupid tick tocks that
everyone's trying to recreate insert
your favorite content creator here at
the end of the day the mcu's true
superpower is its cultural relevance the
fact that it's proven itself worthy of
your time but it's walking on a
tightrope one wrong step or heck not
even a few boring movies and the
relevance is lost the momentum is gone
you're off the train and do you hop back
on minecraft just had a big update and
oh man mr beast just recreated squid
game whoa mandela catalog just updated
and what was i talking about again oh
yeah the mcu stuff yeah i guess i'll get
around to watching hawkeye at some point
what is it they say this is the way the
marvel cinematic universe ends not with
a bang but with a whimper but hey that's
just a theory a film theory and cut
[Music]
[Music]
foreign